a famous ancient Greek once said give me
a place to stand and I shall move the
earth but this wasn't some wizard
claiming to perform impossible feats
it was the mathematician Archimedes
describing the fundamental principle
behind the lever the idea of a person
moving such a huge mass on their own
might sound like magic but chances are
you've seen it in your everyday life one
of the best examples is something you
might recognize from a childhood
playground a teeter totter or seesaw
let's say you and a friend decide to hop
on if you both weigh about the same
you can totter back and forth pretty
easily but what happens if your friend
weighs more suddenly you're stuck up in
the air
fortunately you probably know what to do
just move back on the seesaw and down
you go this may seem simple and
intuitive but what you're actually doing
is using a lever to lift a weight that
would otherwise be too heavy this lever
is one type of what we call simple
machines basic devices that reduce the
amount of energy required for a task by
cleverly applying the basic laws of
physics let's take a look at how it
works every lever consists of three main
components the effort arm the resistance
arm and the fulcrum in this case your
weight is the effort force while your
friend's weight provides the resistance
force what Archimedes learned was that
there is an important relationship
between the magnitudes of these forces
and their distances from the fulcrum the
lever is balanced when the product of
the effort force and the length of the
effort arm equals the product of the
resistance force and the length of the
resistance arm this relies on one of the
basic laws of physics which states that
work measured in joules is equal to
force applied over a distance
lever can't reduce the amount of work
needed to lift something but it does
give you a trade-off increase the
distance and you can apply less force
rather than trying to lift an object
directly the lever makes the job easier
by dispersing its weight across the
entire length of the effort and
resistance arms so if your friend weighs
twice as much as you you'd need to sit
twice as far from the center as him in
order to lift him by the same token his
little sister whose weight is only a
quarter of yours could lift you by
sitting four times as far as you
seesaws may be fun but the implications
and possible uses of levers get much
more impressive than that with a big
enough lever you can lift some pretty
heavy things a person weighing 150
pounds or 68 kilograms could use a lever
just three point seven meters long to
balance a smart car or a 10 meter lever
to lift a 2.5 ton stone block like the
ones used to build the pyramids if you
wanted to lift the Eiffel Tower your
lever would have to be a bit longer
about forty point six kilometers and
what about Archimedes famous Bo's sure
it's hypothetically possible the earth
weighs six times 10 to the 24th power
kilograms and the moon that's about
three hundred and eighty four thousand
four hundred kilometers away would make
a great fulcrum so all you'd need to
lift the earth is a lever with a length
of about a quadrillion light years one
and a half billion times the distance to
the Andromeda galaxy and of course a
place to stand so you can use it so for
such a simple machine the lever is
capable of some pretty amazing things
and the basic elements of levers and
other simple machines are found all
around us in the various instruments and
tools that we and even some other
animals use to increase our chances of
survival or just make our lives easier
after all it's the mathematical
principles behind these devices that
make the world go round